what is that it's the baby's buttocks
she's breech
oh my god i thought she had two heads
let's have a little fun today and check
out one of my favorite shows of all time
friends there's some medical scenes on
there that are questionable and i want
to review them with you let's get
started
am i interrupting oh no dr long please
come in this is ross
he is the father but not the husband
because evidently she can do this alone
i really felt like i was ross growing up
i was the geek i was the nerd
and i've always loved rachel there's
your uterus
and right here
is your baby oh my god
always a really powerful moment when
parents get to see the heartbeat of the
baby
i would usually show the chambers and
the heart beating family gets really
excited it's a special place to be when
you're delivering a baby like as a
family medicine doctor i no longer do it
even though i'm licensed and i know how
i've delivered 38 babies in residency
pretty amazing huh i've seen friends so
many times
i know what she's crying about i don't
see it
it's so funny nowadays it would be less
of an issue because we have like these
3d
ultrasounds that can actually show the
face of the baby we can print out the
pictures
and then the parents go show them around
to their families it's really cute
hi hi this is rachel green i'm ross
geller we called from the car
right we have a semi-private labor room
waiting for you
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm
sorry semi-private we we uh
we asked for a private room yes i see
that here
unfortunately we can't guarantee a
private room and
currently they're all unavailable
hospitals especially in big cities like
new york city they run out of rooms
quickly so sometimes especially when you
first arrive
you can get only a semi-private room and
then like whoever has the most seniority
who's been in the hospital the longest
they may shift you around and move you
to a private room check
these out
it's a funny position for us back in the
day these used to be called stirrups we
tend not to use that word anymore
because weird connotations we now call
them
leg rests or ankle rests or foot rests
what's that
new people when it's your first
pregnancy statistically it takes longer
you have a longer labor if someone's
coming in for their third or fourth baby
usually they process a lot quicker so
you're gonna have multiple roommates if
it's your first you listen to me since i
have been waiting
four women that's four one higher than
the number of centimeters that i am
dilated
have come and gone with their babies i'm
next
it's my turn it's only fair when she
says she's
uh three centimeters dilated what she's
talking about is the opening of the
cervix that's the
uh opening of the uterus the way we
monitor the progression
of labor is through doing an estimate
measurement
usually through a digital exam using our
fingers to
see what that dilation is and three
centimeters dilated is really early in
the labor process
push for five more seconds
my favorite part of this is the resident
or medical student just standing there
that is so accurate
they just stand there aimlessly like
what should i do i'm learning it was me
back in the day that was all of us one
thing is i don't know why the doctor's
not wearing a mask we wear masks
wait i see something what you do you do
oh my god don't say oh my god oh my god
what
what is that what's the baby's butt
she's breech
oh my god i thought you had two heads
breech means the baby is coming out not
head first
coming out butt first which is
problematic you want the baby to come
down and descend the canal
head uh breech has a high rate of
complications
it's gonna be a tricky delivery
especially if it's this far along but i
love that ross took a look and did not
faint because a lot of fathers when they
take a look they're not ready to see
everything that's going on they get a
vasovagal reaction where blood pressure
drops
not enough circulation not enough blood
flow getting to the head and they go
wham i always have my nurses keeping an
eye on the dads while
the mom's delivering you're gonna have
to push even harder nothing's happening
i'm sorry i can't yes you can't hey hey
come on you can i know you can do this
let's go can you annoy you please you do
it for me
what they're missing here is the mom
shouldn't just be pushing aimlessly she
should be doing it along
with the contraction so it should be
time like we get to see the baby monitor
on the side when we see the contraction
starting mom should feel it and at that
point we should have the mom bear down
push count and maybe give a second
effort there
but they're just looks like they're
pushing aimlessly
but is that a newborn baby
[Music]
she's perfect oh wow
she's so tiny
so we always try and get the baby on the
mom's chest as fast as possible we feel
like the best
uh sort of effects happen when the baby
gets rid of the mom's chest mom calms
down it helps lower her blood pressure
slow the heart rate down
baby feels bomb it's like nature at its
finest and while mom is holding the baby
then we let the father
step in and cut the umbilical cord dads
panic when they cut the umbilical cord
because it's kind of rubbery and it
takes a little bit of force
and they don't want to hurt anything so
they're really worried about doing it
it's really cute to watch
and i love that that's like one of my
favorite parts getting the dad involved
to do something right
and you're going into what grade i'm
actually a first year resident but i get
that a lot see i graduated early
on me too that's me every time in the
hospital what are you
ten are you in kindergarten what grade
are you in
are you like uh doogie howser then
occasionally someone would be like wow
you're young that means you must be
smart and i was like
thank you mr tribiani i'm afraid you've
got kidney stones
uh well what else could it be it's
skinny stones
to diagnose kidney stones sometimes we
do an x-ray like that
better tests which we tend to do more
often would be a ct scan with very
specific parameters we could also get an
ultrasound all those are options
better sweetie maybe a little
i wish you hadn't seen me throw up
sometimes the pain can get so bad that
it can lead you to vomit i'm gonna
give you a little revelation here i've
passed kidney stones before
when i was really young didn't drink a
lot of water i drank a lot of soda and i
passed one of these stones and they were
tiny tiny tiny but
boy did it hurt there was blood oh my
god if you ever have to pass one i'm
sorry because it's not a fun experience
so i sympathize with my patients and i
empathize with my man joey here now
ordinarily mr trebiani
we tried to break the stones up with
shockwaves but they're too close to the
bladder now
which means we can either wait for you
to pass them or else go up the urethra
no no no no no nothing is going up okay
up up is not an option what's a urethra
actually up is sometimes an option and
sometimes it's something we have to do
to inspect a bladder another potential
option for patients who are looking to
pass stones is
giving them a medication to help in that
process to relax
the smooth muscles of that area oh my
god
you did it man would you like to see
them
they're so small they're not that small
those are fairly big size
i was in the shower and as i was
cleansing myself
i uh i i well i felt something was it
like a
sneeze only better
no no i mean i mean like a thing on my
body
but what was it well i i don't know it's
it's kind of in a place that's not
it's not visually accessible to me and i
was
hoping maybe you guys could could help
me out why
it's funny because random people tend to
approach me and show me their lesions
quite often i cannot imagine how
dermatologists must feel
that's not a third nipple first of all
it's on your ass
doctors don't say that johnson will you
come in here a moment
i'm with hamilton he's good with weird
things bring him in too
[Music]
it's funny because any time you have a
rare condition in a hospital you're
going to get
resident specialist fellows everyone
coming in
not only to help the case but also to
learn because
we learn from our patients as much as we
help them
you okay ross i don't know
what's in this pie uh i don't know um
butter and eggs and flour
and lime and kiwi can we kiwi
you said it was a key lime pie no i
didn't i said kiwi lime
that's what makes it so special that's
what's gonna kill me
i'm allergic to kiwi russ is
experiencing an anaphylactic attack
his upper airway is literally swelling
it's
closing up that can be quite dangerous
quite quickly
he also has dilation of all of his blood
vessels which drops your blood pressure
quite rapidly your heart rate usually
springs up to compensate for this loss
of pressure
but sometimes the blood pressure effects
can lead you to faint
vomit feel awful have a headache and you
desperately need to get to a place
that has an epinephrine auto injector no
you're not
you're allergic to lobster and peanuts
this reminds me of the scene from hitch
whoa
whoa you're right oh no yeah is your
tongue swelling up
either that at my mouth is getting
smaller
all right get your coat we're gonna go
to the hospital you really should call
9-1-1 in these situations because
uh the ambulance will arrive usually
with an epinephrine auto injector on
board and they could have been asserted
if they need to the last thing you want
is to get in a car and then the swelling
gets worse and then your throat closes
up in the car and you don't know what to
do
so call 9-1-1 for help even if you
actually give yourself an epinephrine
injector you should still head to the er
20 of the time you may need either a
second injection or other interventions
because the first one has failed you
also need to be monitored after you give
yourself epinephrine
your heart rate your blood pressure all
of that there's no way i'm going to get
a shot
and maybe they can take the needle you
know and squirt it into my mouth you're
like like a squirt gun
you have to give the shot you have to
give it quickly way quicker than what
he's experiencing here and you have to
give it right in the anterior lateral
portion of your thigh
that's when you get the most absorption
as fast as possible remember this is an
emergency you had a pitch of saffron it
makes all the difference
this is partially the reason i really
wanted to be a doctor
this scene the admiration monica and
rachel are giving
my man george and i forgot the other
john white
will noah wiley getting all this
attention
i wanted it mostly because no one paid
attention to me now because i was
like huge ego you're gonna walk over to
the operating table you're gonna stop on
that blue mark you're gonna put the tray
down
don't walk too fast but don't dawdle
okay now what if they're truly operating
on this patient why
are all their masks down and why does
phoebe have no gloves on
i don't like what's happening here i
know this is a show inside of a show
inside of a show and we're in inception
land but i still get frustrated because
i want you to have an accurate picture
of what happens
in a hospital system you dig don't know
what i'm doing
but it feels like i'm squaring up the
conversation
how's it going it's going really good
but enough about me come on
where are you from what do you do
i'm a doctor right right i actually i
meant you know
in your spare time do you cook do you
ski or
just hang out with your wife or
girlfriend uh
i don't have a wife or girlfriend but i
i do like to ski oh i love to skate
how amazing is this this conversation
legitimately happens
it happens more actually in the hospital
setting
patients are usually there overnight or
for several days at a time you get quite
lonely so they want to have a
conversation but when it starts crossing
into that territory where they're trying
to get into my personal life and
see if i'm single that gets a little
weird and boundaries need to be set
so are you experiencing any discomfort
no i'm very comfortable
oh my god this reminds me of my
interview that i just did on the daily
show not too long ago
how close is too close ideally you'd
want to keep six feet away from
anyone uh that you're not familiar with
would this be too close
in my medical professional medical
opinion i would say that's too close
so six feet and washing your hands
is this too close that would be too
close awkward
here's two throwback medical drama
reviews er
doogie hauser which one are you gonna
watch watch them both
medical accuracy is not bad in both but
which one are you watching
as always stay happy and healthy